so how did snl end up a humorless hell
a saturday night live alum explains how
the show got so dumb
comedian rob schneider appeared this
week on glenn beck's podcast never heard
of him glenn you know and reflected on
the failing state of his former employer
saturday night live i bet he hates to
crap on his old show
i mean i hate to crap on my old show i
hate to crap
when i saw
when hillary clinton lost
which is understandable
not exactly the most likely person in
the room right and then when kate
mckinnon went out there
on saturday night live from the cold
opening you know like she started
dressed as hillary clinton and she
starts playing hallelujah and i said
i literally praise it please have a joke
at the end
don't do this please don't go down there
and there was no joke at the end and i
went it's over
it's over this is not going to come back
it's like every snl skit
please
is there a joke at the end
and there never is
but he's not wrong the comedians turned
into political hacks and the actors
turned into jokes
now they're about as edgy as brian
stelter's love handles
that's twice now
[Laughter]
and it's still happening in the world of
late night
you can take the comedic indoctrination
process happening with each of the late
night hosts and you could exchange them
with each other that's how you know
that's not interesting anymore it's true
every late night host started playing
the same character self-righteous snob
who hated anyone who wasn't a fellow
elite they're as interchangeable as the
mrs potato head pieces on james van der
beek's giant head
mrs why did we make the choice with mrs
and not mister
anyway well except for one late night
host
who could that be
[Music]
that's beautiful you know jim um you've
been in stand up for what 60 years
half of that half of that yes yes and
you're you're working your way at the
clubs which is good um what do you do
you um do you
uh
uh what's the word i'm looking for do
you hang out with woke comedians at all
do you end up having to share time with
them sometimes yeah what is that like
we just talk about other stuff try to
talk about football based some kind of
sports we don't get involved with the
politics
but they put politics in everything
they do but then when they're hanging
out they pretend like they don't care
they're independent so i don't really
care about politics yeah meanwhile they
do but and they try to go up on stage
with their woke jokes and it doesn't
work and then they get mad i was all
trump supporters in the audience like no
you
your joke just stinks it stinks that's
why
and speaking of stinking saturday live
okay they've been on the air for 47
years it's an hour and a half show
that's how long it's been they got maybe
like 10 iconic sketches yeah in 47 years
if you look at the chappelle show he did
two seasons he's got more iconic
sketches than saturday live yeah that's
a good point yeah i mean so it's it's
overrated saturday night live is almost
like you too
they got like 10 iconic songs oh boy and
everything they put out after that
stinks they haven't put a good album out
since 1997.
everything else they got 10 and that's
it oh boy look at it no it's funny i
love you
but i can't argue with that that's what
they are that's what saturday night live
is i mean the first three u2 albums are
amazing yeah and then they have zuropa
comes back and then after that
everything kind of went how to dismantle
an atomic bomb yeah and then remember
they gave you one yeah they gave you
three albums
nobody wanted nobody wanted
to be automatically downloaded
you should give this away
with a real book
there's many right there
what do you make do you agree with rob
schneider the problem is a lot a lot of
people they don't nobody watches like a
lot of people
criticize snl but don't watch it i
actually watch it i mean i faithfully
watch it yeah i think it's funny until
they talk politics i also think it's
funny until they invite a guest host on
that's not even a comedian right i mean
and i have nothing bad to say about kim
kardashian but when she was on people
were like what is she promoting her sex
tape came out years ago
[Laughter]
and she's not a comedian so they don't
even think it's out on dvd now i think
yes
of course it's in your rolodex yes
my
rolodex my rotary phone
no but it's just i mean when they bring
in politics and i absolutely agree with
schneider that hallelujah i was waiting
for a joke i'm like this is depressing
that was the whole thing it was like it
was so sad the onion does this now
they'll do like a serious headline
because it's like life is so bad guy can
late night be saved
i think you're saving it there that's
all you have to say
i i forgive you for coming dressed as a
restaurant valet
[Laughter]
i thought it was like an infomercial on
how we could all make money
that's better yeah let's make that
better
you sell the reverse reverse mortgage
or vasectomy
that is a reverse reverse mortgage
yes it is there you go you can keep your
mortgage if you reverse yeah oh yeah
last word uh tyrus look it it comes down
to just one thing uh when you pick a
side you lose and the comedy is supposed
to be objective and aren't the same
thing with us if we went super red all
the time sorry we would end up in the
same boat but yeah i don't think
anyone's made for in front of the
president
trump during his time when it was
warranted then we did yeah you know so
we don't pick sides and once you pick a
side the art form's gone yeah but also
even if you pick a side at least have a
sense of humor about your side and you
pick a side that's not even on social
media anymore yeah and the other side's
doing that we can only we couldn't even
make up yeah i mean someone shakes hands
with their invisible friend in front of
tv there's some jokes there
yeah i mean the only time they tried to
make fun of them remember jim carrey
played bin laden uh uh biden and he had
the sunglass on like he was some like
cool guy there's nothing cool about joe
biden no that they do that their idea
they when they say they're making fun of
somebody like hillary it's so
soft and it's always laughing with the
character they go but we do lampoon no
you don't who am i talking to all right
coming up it took some bravado to lock
thermostats in colorado hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else